[Music]
breaking news tonight
america locked down near total lockdown
complete standstill it is very scary
a year ago a scary virus made an
unrelenting
march we're at war and we're fighting
an invisible enemy an invisible enemy
that made
us disappear silencing
the roar of rush hour
and leaving the city that never sleeps
still
as a photograph
[Music]
go inside those buildings today and you
find an
eerie time capsule a strange still life
of life still as we left it
have you wondered what about that plant
on my desk
well there's good news some survived
even thrived with the run of the place
buzzfeed brought four floors of plants
to huddle together in this conference
room
most made it others drooped as if to
match
our moods schools shuttered before kids
could put together the pieces
leaving playgrounds and classrooms
achingly empty
except for the parking lot
experiments moved out of the lab showing
the effect of time
on a banana and an apple left in a
locker
time marched on but calendars on their
own
couldn't turn the page from march 2020
fittingly it was friday the 13th of
march here at the smithsonian's museum
of natural history
where preserving the past is what they
do
we have closed our new york broadcast
center to clean
and disinfect in our cbs this morning
offices
it's still march 11 2020 on the
assignment board
they told everyone not to return to work
in the rush to leave
producers thought ahead and preserved
the moment
this is absolutely insane but we're
going home one day we'll look back on
this video and it will just be a memory
but that day hasn't come yet
a year later our abandoned desks still
hold what almost
feel like clues time lapse the big
goodbye
in one office four bags of girl scout
cookies one co-worker
never got to hand out another colleague
still out of state now only sees her
apartment
on this security camera sadly
over half a million americans will never
go back home
but as with trials faced by earlier
generations
america will persevere we said it back
then
we're going to get through it and we're
going to be okay yeah but what image
will come to define that return
what photo will say we're back
we're still looking for cbs this morning
i'm chip reed